When I talk about selling ideas, here's an example.
There's a company called Better Works here.
They sell an online service to help you reward your employees better...
...or treat your employees better.
For them, they sell the idea that you should treat your employees well.
It might sound very silly but why should you treat your employees well,...
...how can you treat your employees well and so on.
They don't sell their product but when people learn about it,...
...they learn from them, they learn tips, they get a lot of value there,...
...and then they wanna actually subscribe or sign up with that company.
If you were a writing coach,...
...instead of selling people your writing services,...
...you should sell them on the idea of why should they write,...
...why should they write a book.
So again, it's much more powerful if you sell ideas not stuff...
...and you'll find that if you start sharing your best expertise...
...for free out there whether it's through a blog, book, e-book,...
...webinar, video, like these videos, Docstoc is doing it,
...people will really respond to you.
You are gonna get a lot more referrals, a lot more clients...
And actually you're gonna feel a lot better...
...because you're making a difference without selling people...
...so educate, don't sell.